KEN ARTHUR: Hi, everybody.
I'm Ken Arthur.
I recently joined the
Talks at Google team,
so I'm here to
introduce this talk.
So without further ado, I'd like
to introduce Brian Kesinger.
Brian joined Disney when he
was 18, becoming the youngest
animator at the company.
He started as a layout animator
on Tarzan and his career
has filled many positions,
ranging from visual development
to story artist.
Today he's going to talk
about his career, his art,
and his series of books
featuring Victoria
and her pet land octopus, Otto.
So, Brian.
BRIAN KESINGER: Thank you.
Hey, everyone.
Thank you so much for coming out
today and giving up your lunch
hour.
It's fun.
We had these sort of talks
at the studio, as well.
And I'm usually sitting
where you're sitting,
so it's very strange for me to
be on this side of the podium.
So bear with me if I
have minor freak outs
or am at a loss for words.
So as you heard in
the introduction,
I'm currently the head of
story on one of our projects
at Disney right now.
So I primarily make my home
in the storyboard department
at Walt Disney
animation studios.
I affectionately refer
to it as the day job.
And I've been there,
now, for 20 years.
As was mentioned in my
intro, I started on Tarzan
as a hand-drawn-- back
in the old timey days
where we drew things on paper--
drew backgrounds for Tarzan.
It's also during
that film that I
started to learn a little
bit about computer animation
with some of the
deep canvas stuff we
were doing on that film.
From there I moved
on to Atlantis.
Thank you.
And Treasure Planet, again
both in the layout department.
But with each film, starting
to learn more and more computer
graphics and how they
related to animation.
Before I jumped on to Bolt,
which was my first all CG film
that I worked on-- so I
transitioned from hand drawing
layout to digital
layout, which became more
like traditional cinematography
on live action films.
And from there
went on to Tangled,
Wreck It Ralph, Big
Hero 6 and Zootopia.
And I just finished
working on Moana,
which will come out this fall.
So all during that time
where I drew for the studio,
it was also very important
for me to draw for fun.
And so I'd always carry
my sketchbook around
and draw everything
from a fierce samurai
to brooding minotaurs.
Because I'm a big D&D geek.
Cyber ninja's, drunk
monkeys, more drunk monkeys,
and cool dirt bike kids.
And then one day
someone had contacted
me, a good friend
of mine, said hey,
I'm having a
steampunk tea party.
Will you draw an illustration
for the invitation?
I'm like sure, what's steampunk?
And then I googled steampunk
and found out what it was.
And I'm like, oh
that's really cool.
And so I did this
illustration, and there
was something that really
drew me to this genre.
You know all the great
Victorian fashion
was a key component to me, that
I really love about steampunk.
And then all the kind of
sci-fi, retro sci-fi elements,
were really fun for
me to play with.
And something that
I realized I had
dipped into a little
while working on Atlantis
and Treasure Planet.
Had kind of that
steampunk feel to it.
So I already had some
muscle memory into it.
So I started on this endeavor,
which I call the Tea Girls,
and these were illustrations
that really celebrated
the prettier side of steampunk.
If you were to
look up steampunk,
oftentimes it's a lot of
post-apocalyptic stuff.
Or ray guns and
big giant robots.
And I saw kind of a
hole in the genre where
it's like, well let's
focus on the pretty things.
Let's focus on something
that's a little more
positive and bohemian.
And so I thought,
well why not do that?
Just to talk a little
bit about my inspiration
for these pieces,
this is an illustrator
by the name of Arthur Rackham.
Do you guys-- have
you heard of him?
Pretty amazing artist.
Kind of known for
his illustrations
in the original Alice
in Wonderland novels.
And really cool.
As you can see in
the art here, it's
more about draftsmanship
and line work,
and the color is more wash.
Kind of ink washes
and watercolor.
And the drawing is really the
superstar of his illustrations.
And I consider myself more of
a draftsman than a painter.
So when I see people that can
do illustration work like that,
it really inspires me.
Another great artist
is Leyendecker.
And he was a tremendous artist.
Kind of similar, I
guess, to Norman Rockwell
in that he would do a lot
of covers for the Post
and that sort of thing.
But why I like him
more than Rockwell
is-- it's kind of small
in the image here--
but things are a little
more graphic and stylized.
If you were to look at
the ringlets of her hair,
it's a little more
sculptural than photo real.
Still, you look at the image
and it looks very photo real.
But there's little
tweaks here and there
that make it all
the more special.
Also what I like
about his work is
he just includes the props that
are necessary for the scene.
It's not a full illustration,
it's kind of a graphic design.
You can see that on a
t-shirt or a poster.
But everything is there to
really set the scene that
needs to be there.
And you'll see how that has
become part of my work as well.
Charles Dana Gibson.
These are-- another
illustrator who
primarily worked in line work.
He's creator of the
Gibson Girl, which
was kind of a very Victorian
poster girl for the era.
And I just love his work.
You look at this, and it's
just one solid line of action.
From the head to the
hem of the dress.
And everything
else in that image
really supports
the main feature,
which is the woman
reading the book there.
And it's just all of his
illustrations are really good.
Just being super clear,
even though there's
lots of sketchy lines in there
and it's a pretty dense image,
your eye knows
right where to look.
Between the balance of
composition and also value,
which is kind cool.
Brian Froud, of course
you guys know Brian Froud.
A concept designer
in the 80s for Jim
Henson, and worked
on a lot of the work
on Dark Crystal and Labyrinth.
I'm a kid of the
80s, so anything 80s
is-- I'm really into.
And certainly Brian
Froud, I remember
getting the art books
back in the day when
I saw those movies.
It's like, wow this is amazing.
And he does a lot
of fantasy art.
A lot of cool
fairies and dragons
and these troll guys, here.
As mentioned before,
Mike Mignola.
Who I didn't know until
working on Atlantis.
Wasn't familiar with his work
because I was more of a Disney
geek than a comic book geek.
And he was an early concept
designer on Atlantis,
so I really dug his work
and his use stark values.
Again, being a drafts
person and not a painter,
I love that most of the
work is put into the line
work and shadow areas.
And then the color itself
is actually pretty flat.
But still very, very effective.
And then, of course, these two.
Bill Watterson.
My first memory
of comics was when
my dad gave me the
first collection
of Calvin and Hobbes.
And I was little, and
I remember thinking,
oh wow what a cool
coloring book.
Because all the comic strips
were in black and white.
So I colored most of them.
[LAUGHTER]
But that got me to
know the art even more,
spending time with these two.
Just amazing storytelling.
And that's something I want
to stress with this talk today
is how much storytelling
you can get into one image.
It's something that we do
in the movies at Disney,
we control every
pixel of the frame.
And so you better make sure
that the pixel has earned
its way into the picture.
Well, the same thing with
drawing and illustration.
That's why, in older books,
there was usually only one
illustration per chapter.
A picture is worth
a thousand words.
It holds true.
In every little detail, you want
to consider before putting in.
And these artists that I showed
you certainly do all of that.
And then I mentioned doing
reference into steampunk.
There's no shortage of steampunk
imagery on the internet.
And what was great was when I
was first starting out a my Tea
Girl adventure, these
were all strangers to me.
But amazing artists.
And usually all makers
and working in 3-D space.
Sculptural, jewelry,
that sort of thing.
But there wasn't
a lot of 2-D art.
So I thought, oh maybe
there's an opportunity
to jump in and play
with these guys.
And the result of that were
these five original paintings
here.
Another thing that was
important for me in this process
was that, since I had
made the complete switch
to digital animation at work,
I was missing the drawing.
I was missing putting
pencil on paper.
And so this was an opportunity
to create something physical.
Something analog,
which also played
into the steampunk aesthetic.
In this digital age, you have
these people that are still
interested in having objects.
And I thought,
well why not-- why
create just another
piece of digital art
that's just a file
on a computer,
and do something special.
So I did these five paintings.
And they're all painted
with tea, something
that I thought also fits
into the genre of steampunk.
And using different flavors
for different paintings
in different shades.
I would treat it with
just a dab of watercolor,
but for the most part it's tea.
And it's what gives it,
also, that splatter feel,
that energy to it.
It was actually by accident,
because I was researching, well
how do you make stuff look old.
And the internet told me,
well you age it with tea.
And I said, great.
And I didn't finish
reading the article.
But I went and
made a lot of tea,
and I took a tea bag out and
just started squirting it
all over the paper.
And I said, internet you lied
to me, this looks terrible.
And I had already done all the
line work, because I'm stupid.
And the tea went everywhere.
But my wife came over and she
says, well that smells good.
And then she said--
and I said, yes.
Smells good, but
looks like crap.
And she says, no, I think
it looks kind of cool.
You might as well finish it.
If it's already ruined you're
not going to ruin it more.
And I finished
it, and I actually
kind of like how they came out.
And it did develop into
something that became
a signature for me, as well.
Which was kind of cool.
As you start to see more
stuff make the rounds,
you see that splatter effect.
And you know, oh Brian
probably had a hand in that.
So just to go into the
process of these tea
paintings a little bit.
I always carry my sketchbook
with me wherever I go.
And I do kind of what I call
Ouija board drawing, which
is just trying to move
my pencil on the page
and discovering what the
drawing is going to be.
Rather than have an
image in my head.
And I kind of just
move along the page
and find different
things that interest me.
Different shapes
that interest me.
But the main thing for me at
this stage is flow and rhythm.
Not so much form and
solid drawing, but just
what kind of cool
gestures can I get.
Once I'm happy with that,
I do a blue line sketch
on some pretty thick
watercolor paper.
That's important,
because I'm going to be
putting a lot of tea on it.
And the watercolor paper will
soak it up and not ruin itself.
Once I'm happy
with the blue line,
I'll go over the blue line
with a really thin micron pen.
It's like a point .01 millimeter
tip, because these drawings are
actually pretty small.
Those ones I posted were
five by five inches.
And then once I'm happy with
that, then I ruin it with tea.
And for this one, because
it was a steampunk geisha,
I decided to use green tea.
So it has a little
bit-- and that's kind
of the initial
layer where I'm just
letting it splatter and pool
and do what it wants to do.
And then I'll go in with
a paint brush into my tea
and mix in a little
watercolor, and go in and just
push and pull values to get
to a finished piece like this.
So, again, it's organic.
It's happy accidents.
All that kind of
fun Bob Ross stuff
put into steampunk
kind of veneer.
These are some of my favorites
that I've done over time.
Different flavors.
Different compositions.
[INAUDIBLE]
And the purpose with
those-- actually,
going back to those real quick.
Because I did stories all day,
making stories was my job,
I wanted to come home
and not make stories.
I wanted to just create art
that existed on its own.
And could go in a
frame and there.
Say I'm done.
But I couldn't help, as I was
spending time with these girls,
to create stories with them.
And I think it
was just something
in the back of my
head that is like, OK.
Well, what's this
person's story and how do
they relate to this person then.
And so I thought,
OK, well let me
try to tell a story in the
steam world with this aesthetic.
And I started to think
about how we create stories
at Disney, which is a
thing about universal ideas
and themes.
Examples of these
are pretty obvious.
There's the overprotective
parent, which we all get.
Either we have
one or we are one.
That's an idea that
we can all understand.
It's when you tell that idea
through the world of fish
that it becomes
very interesting.
And animation, to
me, is a metaphor.
Right?
It's a way for us
to tell stories.
They're fables.
There's other moments in your
life, like your first kiss.
Which we can all relate to.
But, again, when you do it
over spaghetti with two dogs
it becomes charming
and memorable.
And then there can be
even deeper emotions,
like dealing with
guilt. You know,
when it's a little puppet
whose nose grows when he tells
a lie it seems childish
and fun, but there's still
heart behind it.
And it's why we get
behind these characters.
So I'm thinking about
general ideas, what's
something we can all relate to.
And then my wife
and I got a puppy
and we thought, well there's
lots of universal ideas
around raising a pet.
And I thought, well.
OK, so a pet in
the steampunk era.
What would be a really
good steampunk pet?
And I thought, well an octopus.
Because octopus are
amazing creatures,
and they had kind of become
the theme animal for steampunk,
if you will.
So I thought of that old
classic 1920s illustration
where you had the high society
lady walking a greyhound.
And I thought, well what's
a steampunk spin on that?
That would probably be a high
society lady with green hair,
walking her pet octopus
to the fire hydrant.
Obviously.
And as soon as
you start thinking
of your universal
idea, then everything
just becomes an overlay.
Right?
And the hard work
is kind of done.
Because you think, OK.
Well you have a pet.
Obviously they're going to
have accidents in the house.
And how would an octopus
have an accident?
Well, they would ink everywhere.
Bath time, of course.
Otto is the only octopus that
actually doesn't like water.
So that becomes particularly
troublesome for Victoria.
And then I went to my sketchbook
and I just created a list.
This is my writing process.
I'm so much more visually driven
that the less writing on paper
I have to do, the better.
But it did help as I was
planning out the first book,
Walking Your Octopus.
A checklist of all different
scenarios, both pros and cons.
And you can see, I couldn't help
but even doodle on these pages
as well.
And then once the boring
writing letters part was done,
I could go and just start to
do these very rough vignettes.
Again, going back to
the Leyendecker arts,
what props do I need
to sell the idea?
Nothing more, nothing less.
And these scribbly
drawings then get
into even scribble-- even
more scribbly drawings.
This is-- can't you tell?
It's Victoria offering a fish
to Otto if he sits up pretty.
Obviously.
But the main thing for me in
this sketch is A, the idea.
OK, she's training
him with a fish.
And B, what's the
compositional elements in this.
And you can see
that long line, just
like in Gibson's work, of
her arm and the contrast
by the squiggly line of
Otto looking up at the fish.
You get a nice
triangle composition.
So once I have those
notes down for me,
that's the hardest part.
That's done.
Then I can go and
make it look pretty.
But this is the more
boring part for me.
Where it's just, OK.
Finish the line work.
Finish the colors.
But the idea is what's
important to me.
And with visual
storytelling the idea
is the most important thing.
I think that's what's
great about seeing
so much are on the
internet, is that it's
not about skill necessarily.
It's about the idea.
Does it make you feel something?
Does it make you laugh?
Some of my favorite web comics
are not drawn well at all.
But I love them and
there's a charm to them.
It's something I like
to encourage people
with, if you have ideas, is not
to be intimidated by your skill
level.
It's the thought that counts.
So I thought I'd show
this to you guys.
It's a time lapse of one of my
pieces from start to finish.
I draw in Photoshop for these
Otto and Victoria pieces,
just because it's easier to keep
digital versions handy if I do
shirts and that sort of thing.
But we'll give this a watch.
It's about 5 minutes long.
I'll give some
commentary over it,
as a chance for you to look
at art and not hear me.
So-- Yeah, this was a
piece pretty early on.
This was actually my second
Otto and Victoria piece.
And you can see,
this whole video
is about six hours worth of work
boiled down to five minutes.
You can see how roughly
I banged everything out,
compositionally.
And now I'm going in and
refining a rough sketch.
This isn't, still,
the final line.
This is still rough.
I find that when I
draw, the more work I
put into the rough
phase-- that's
where all of the
thinking and weight
is-- then the easier the
rest of the piece goes.
So now that I'm
happy with the rough,
I'm going in and doing
more fine line work.
You can see it start
to come into focus,
like an old timey Polaroid.
And it's in this phase that
I'm using all of the old school
animation line work techniques.
Thick and thin.
Thick line at the bottom of an
object, where there's weight.
Thin line at the top,
where there's not.
Straights against curves.
Getting the fabric to feel
like it's in movement.
Little things, like
here on this umbrella.
Those little dangly beads.
It's one thing if I would have
just drawn them hanging down,
but because they're
kind of at an angle,
gives some movement
to the whole thing.
And then suction cups.
Millions and millions
of suction cups.
And this is another
example of why
you should do your
homework, because you
can see as I'm drawing these
hundreds of suction cups--
it wasn't until after this
piece that I researched.
Octopus only have two
rows of suction cups--
[LAUGHTER]
--on each of their arms.
So that's how you can tell
my older Otto and Victoria
drawings from my newer,
is by the suction cups.
If there is a stupid
amount of suction cups,
they're early ones.
If there's two, I've done
my homework and research.
But you can see, too, I'm
adding a lot of weight
to these tentacles.
How they're drawn, they feel
like there's some mass to them
and the bottom side that's
touching the ground is flat.
And the top side is
more curvy, because this
is an octopus that's on land.
So it's not going to be as
flowy as you would draw them
under the water.
But they have a
little more weight.
And so now that the final
art is done, final line art,
I'm going to go through
and do a shadow pass.
And this is where we're digging
into Mike Mignola territory.
Where there's these really kind
of comic book inking lines,
but on softer forms.
So it's kind of a
fun mash up for me.
Whereas normally
this style of inking
is used to draw Captain
America fighting Red Skull,
I'm using it to draw
very elegant ladies
and fanciful octopus.
And it appeals to me.
And, again, because
I'm a drafts person
I spend more time on the drawing
side than the painting side.
As you'll see here,
the painting side
is mostly pretty flat painting.
Because all the volume and form
is described by the line work
and not by the gradients,
highlights, or shadows.
And again, I think it gives
it more of an animation feel.
Which is why when people see
this work-- not knowing that I
work at Disney-- say, oh.
It reminds me of Disney.
I'm like, OK.
Good.
I'm doing something right.
The green hair on Victoria was
kind of an afterthought, too.
So much of steampunk
is muted colors.
In fact, the joke
is steampunk is when
Goth people discover brown.
And so I wanted,
again, for my art
to stand out in
the sea of sepia.
And I thought, well
what better than to give
a color pop to Victoria and
give her that green hair.
And what's been fun is
at conventions and stuff,
when you see people dressed
up in steampunk, every once
in a while you'll see
a girl with green hair.
And that's a pretty
cool feeling,
knowing that you've had some
influence on the group that
has been so accepting.
Steampunk people are amazing.
So we're wrapping up
towards the end of this.
This step right here, with
all that mottled texture--
I had scanned one of
my tea splatter pages.
Just with no art on it, so I can
overlay it on my Photoshop file
to give it a more organic feels.
So it doesn't just
feel like digital art.
So that's where
you get all the fun
splotches on Otto and Victoria.
So that's that.
A couple of my favorite
pieces from the first book.
This is Otto and
Victoria at the dog park.
Because it's very important
to socialize your pet octopus.
You don't want them
being a bad pet.
These are all dogs of either
mine or my friends, my family.
So it's kind of a
photo album for us.
This is Octopus By The Sea,
great for leisurely Sunday
boat rides.
They are navigators, musicians,
and can pour a nice cup
of tea for you as well.
Octopus love holidays,
so the more you
can involve them into your
holiday routine the more
they'll take to it.
So they're really good
at jack o' lanterns.
And then bath time.
Of course, he's a gentleman
he's not going to peak.
But he is there to help you out
at the end of a really, really
tough day.
And then bed time.
This was certainly
inspired by my kids,
when I would often fall
asleep before they did.
But the octopus loves to
cuddle its favorite submarine
as it's off into dreamland,
being read its favorite story.
20,000 Leagues Under the Sea.
And that is a
Cthulhu in the box,
just in case you're wondering.
Another fun thing to do
with these characters
is to mash them up
with pop culture.
I find they cross over really
well, they love to cosplay.
So any chance I can meld
them with my interests
is always a win for me.
And then the first book
got pretty popular.
I was really honored
by how much it was
going around and being shared.
And so the time came
to do another one,
and this was Traveling
With Your Octopus,
and this was a
chance for me to go
more global with my steampunk.
A lot of steampunk seems
to be very European based,
but I wanted to play
with that a little.
And so I did some
American steampunk,
with the Wild West
or the weird West.
Scotland, of course.
Bagpiping on the Moors.
In India, playing around.
Making the trek
across the Sahara.
The only thing more stubborn
than an octopus is a camel,
we all know this is fact.
Again, in all of these
illustrations-- even
in going around the world--
I'm only including the details
that I need.
You can see they all have the
striped background behind them.
And it's really just
setting the scene,
putting the characters
in the forefront.
I think that's also--
personally, for me
I spent the early
part of my career
just drawing backgrounds--
that I'd now like, screw that.
I just want to draw
the characters.
And it's laziness.
But the really special thing,
and what's really touched me--
and it's something that being
an artist on the internet
these days, that you
wouldn't have gotten even
when I started back in
'96-- is the fan community.
And people sending
you posts, or using
a hashtag Otto and Victoria.
And then seeing this
beautiful, amazing cosplay.
I had done some steampunk
artwork for Disneyland
and we did an opening
there, and what
was great was this
person on the bottom left
had dressed up as
Victoria at Disneyland.
And what was amazing for me,
and I still get goose bumps,
is when I was walking
through Disneyland
I saw her and kids taking
their picture with her, one
of my characters at Disneyland.
It was a subversive kind of,
hey, that's kind of cool.
And then it continued
with amazing tattoos,
kids sending in
artwork because they
love Victoria's green hair.
This was kind of a
fun full circle mashup
for me, when someone sent
me a Calvin and Hobbes Otto
and Victoria drawing.
Balloon art, because
everyone loves balloon art.
And my favorite, Otto
and Victoria LEGOs.
So pretty cool.
But then, in the height of
this thing, what really struck
me is when my friend told
me, hey if you write Google--
if you Google Walking Your,
the first thing will be dog,
the second thing will be cat,
and the third will be octopus.
So I'm doing something right.
And sharing this anecdote
here makes me even happier.
So it was this work with
these two characters.
A strong friendship between
unlikely people, especially one
that can't talk, that got
Marvel calling me and saying we
have a couple of
characters that we
think you'd be really good at.
They're very odd and unique
friends, and one of them
can't really talk.
Well he's got a very limited
vocabulary, at least.
Would you mind doing
a comic with us?
And I thought, no.
You guys are kidding.
In fact, the first
couple of emails
I got from them I
thought was spam.
Because it just said
Greetings From Marvel
in the subject line.
And I'm like, delete.
[LAUGHTER]
And it wasn't until the sixth
one that I actually read it,
and it said that they
want to work with me.
And I'm like, oh.
OK, I'll read through next time.
But it was great.
Guardians of the Galaxy
had just come out last year
and Groot was kind of a
runaway character for them
so they wanted to give him
his own six issue mini series.
And they said that they had
seen my Otto and Victoria work
and saw how expressive I could
get with a character that
really only had eyes, and
wanted kind of an animated
feel for their Groot book.
So these are a few of
my pages, and this is
my first time doing comic art.
And I was really flattered
when they told me
they wanted me to do
pencils, inking, and color.
So all the art for the book.
And then I got really stressed
when they told me they wanted
pencils, inks, and full color.
And I'm like, I
still work at Disney.
And they're like, I know.
I know.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm proud of the work.
I really did treat it like
it was an animated movie,
using color and tone.
This was pretty early
on, where Groot really
has a desire to see the galaxy.
So I really wanted to pump up
the saturation of that moment,
to really heighten the
emotional moment for him.
Of course, it's
Marvel so there's
going to be big epic battles.
Especially when they're
fighting cyberspace sharks.
And so, you know, it was fun
to do these kind of full page
Marvel-esque drawings.
But still in a
very cartoony way.
Another thing I found
in doing this book
was because the
characters are so
weird, the more we can
ground their environment
and where they are in
relatable places, the more easy
it is to digest.
It's something we talked
about on Treasure Planet.
We had the 70/30
rule, where something
had to be 70% recognizable
and then just have
a 30% tweak on it.
So if you look at the
ships in Treasure Planet,
they look like sailing ships.
It's not until you look a little
closer and you see, oh wait.
Those are like space
engines on the back
and they're floating
and that sort of thing.
So stuff like this, where
the script pages called
for Rocket and Groot
to be discussing
their plans in a space port.
I made it look like
a diner, and just
kind of a roadhouse
sort of thing
that we could all relate to.
This was a fun
moment where Groot
has a fantasy of joining the
Marvel universe where all
the heroes are Groot versions.
So you have Iron
Groot, Spidergroot,
the Incredible Groot,
Howard the Groot, and then,
of course, Grootlactus
and the Silver Grooter.
Which was pretty fun.
And of course
during the sequence,
Groot is totally fangirling
and that drawing of Groot
is kind of how I felt during
this whole process of drawing
it.
Like I was getting to play with
these amazing action figures.
In the story, Rocket
and Groot get separated
and that presented
a writing challenge
in that Groot-- Rocket always
serves as Groots translator.
So if you don't have him, how
is the reader going to relate?
How are we going to get
what Groot is saying?
And the writer of this series
of books, Jeff Loveness,
is an amazing writer.
Works for Jimmy Kimmel,
that's his day job.
Came up with this
great concept in that
the word bubbles, "I am
Groot" would become the frame
for what he's actually saying.
It's hard to see in
this stage, but he's
saying I am Groot
in the first page
and the illustration
within those letters
are Rocket being taken
away by space pirates.
And I thought that was
so clever in that it
gives a visual subtext.
So the reader instantly
becomes a translator
for Groot, which is pretty cool.
This is another fun scene to
illustrate, how the two met.
In some fun visual
storytelling here, you
can tell on the bottom
frame their relationship
to each other just by how
they're sitting and acting.
And on the next page,
when you turn the page,
you see that Rocket actually
stands up for Groot.
And we revisit that page,
and now they're buddies.
And again, all the
little details.
How they're sitting
next to each other.
It is literally,
too-- industry secret,
here-- it is the same drawing.
Thank goodness for
Photoshop layers.
I just move them together, so
that saved me about 30 minutes.
This was another fun panel.
This is Rocket and
Groot reminiscing
about their adventures.
And it was fun to play around
with the framing, something
that we don't get to do in film.
Because in film you're locked
into the rectangle, right?
Or a square, if
you're old school.
But it's a locked frame
for the entire piece.
In comics, you really get to
blow the doors open on staging.
Even on this piece,
using branches
to break the frame instead
of the normal white boundary
boxes.
There's a character we
meet in this series,
and she's called Numinus.
She's the goddess
of fate and chance.
And when Groot meets
her in the story,
she's feeling rather guilty
because all the fate and chance
that she's done
has usually turned
out bad for these characters
in the Marvel universe.
Something as simple as being bit
by a spider, for Peter Parker,
ultimately, could be argued,
led to the death of Gwen Stacy.
So on and so forth.
So, she's kind of
in a down place.
But Groot, in his
own special way,
reminds her of all the
good that has come,
and all the good moments.
And this frame was
really hard to work on.
The page-- the written
page described it
as, "Groot describes all the
wonderful things of the Marvel
universe within the
words, I am Groot."
Right, thanks buddy.
So it that took
forever to lay out,
but I'm really proud of it.
And, again, it means something.
It comes at an emotional
point of the story.
So it's not just about
drawing for drawings sake,
it does have a place in the
story and an emotional beat.
And I was really happy
that I got the two Captain
Americas in the letter A. I
just geek out with all of you.
So it was-- that time in that
part of the galaxy had ended
and it was wonderful.
And then I decided to play
in another galaxy that
was more far, far away.
And the Force Awakens
had just come out
and, again, I love
Calvin and Hobbes.
And I thought, well I'm going to
mix peanut butter and chocolate
together and mash up Calvin
and Hobbes and Star Wars.
Which, honestly, is
not an original idea.
Everyone's kind of
done their pass--
there's Doctor Who mashups,
there's-- anything is mashed up
with Calvin and Hobbes.
Eventually I want to do a
mashup of Calvin and Hobbes
with Calvin and Hobbes,
just to be meta.
c in the meantime,
I've been doing this.
Which was more just kind of
overlays of traditional Calvin
and Hobbes comics with
the new characters.
And it was really
a fun chance for me
to play in Bill
Watterson's style.
He has such a neat style.
I really encourage you guys
to look at the art online
when you can or pull out
the books that you have,
because that guy
could draw anything.
And drawing a TIE fighter
in Bill Watterson's style
is a really fun challenge.
c it wasn't until I drew this
one where Han Solo says, "You
know, he gets this from
your side of the family,"
that I realized
there was a deeper
connection between Calvin
and Hobbes and Star Wars.
And that's-- has anyone
seen Force Awakens?
You guys have seen it?
Yeah.
So Kylo Ren-- spoiler
alert-- Kylo Ren
is the son of Princess
Leia and Han Solo.
And after watching the
movie I thought, wow.
He must have been the
ultimate problem child.
How must it have been in
that household growing up?
And then I look at
the Calvin strips
and, you know, the whole idea
of those terrible snowmen
that he would make.
And the fact that he would be
using one as target practice
is maybe a little dark.
But it's funny.
And I think if you continue
that metaphor even further, well
of course Kylo Ren's imaginary
friend would not be a tiger.
It would be Darth Vader.
And these two in their Star
Killer tree fort would plan
rebel attacks against
the girl, Suzy Durkin's.
Or Rey, in this case,
and her little droid.
So again, that
whole relationship
between Calvin and Suzy really
tended to play out really well.
And it was my first
genuine experience
of something going
viral, which was pretty
exciting to be a part of.
I did these original
six images on a Monday,
and by Thursday
they were featured
on Huffington Post, Hollywood
Reporter, Entertainment Weekly.
Ultimately getting a
call from Time Magazine.
So it was pretty interesting,
the power of fandom
and the internet
teaming together
can really do some fun things.
Of course, the
complicated relationship
between Kylo Ren and Rey--
who knows where it ends?
Maybe they'll be brother and
sister, like Luke and Leia.
Then this will be extra creepy.
But worse things have happened
in the Star Wars galaxy.
And then, of course, babysitter.
You know, mom and
dad want a day out
so Uncle Lando is
going to come by.
"So...
Does your mom ever
talk about me?"
"These babysitter's
getting worse every time."
So it's fun taking
quotes from the movie
and putting a fun spin on it.
Childish spin.
And, of course, little Kylo
will never go in mother's closet
ever again.
Bath time is always an
intergalactic struggle.
"The first order will
not stand for this!"
"Your first order
is to take a bath."
You know, dumb puns like that.
But at the end of the day
mom is always there for you,
to kiss you and your
stuffed animal goodnight.
No matter how
complicated of an issue
you might have with
your own father.
So that's kind of it
for my presentation.
Do you guy have any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: I noticed
that you numbered
all the tentacles of Otto.
But obviously, didn't,
you know-- they're not
including the final drawing.
It looks like you draw
all eight tentacles,
no matter the perspective.
BRIAN KESINGER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that on purpose?
Or--
BRIAN KESINGER:
It is on purpose.
And I do that on the
final illustrations.
If I'm signing and
doodling, I'll only do four.
Just for everyone's comfort.
But, yeah.
I do try to keep track of
them, just because it's
a fun challenge for me to come
up with eight ideas in one
drawing.
And then, like I
said, he's a gentleman
so we want to make sure
that all eight tentacles are
present at all times.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So actually,
we've met before.
I'm an artist as well.
BRIAN KESINGER: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, from
like comic-con and stuff.
BRIAN KESINGER: Awesome.
Yeah good to see you again.
AUDIENCE: I was
really curious, when
I watched-- was watching the
play by play of the digital art
and stuff.
First of all, just sort
of a double question,
what tool do you use to
draw into the computer?
BRIAN KESINGER: Oh, yeah.
I forgot.
I draw in Photoshop
and I use a Cintiq.
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's a Cintiq?
BRIAN KESINGER:
Yeah, it's a Cintiq.
AUDIENCE: I'm so jealous of you.
BRIAN KESINGER: I'm
spoiled with it, too.
AUDIENCE: I believe it.
I've got a Wacom Bamboo,
so I'm-- I'll get there
eventually.
And then I was wondering if--
did you, for the line drawing--
you probably don't
need it because you
are so experienced
with drafting,
but do you ever use the
pen tool in Photoshop
to get that final crisp line?
BRIAN KESINGER: No, I don't.
Yeah, because I have
some custom brushes
that I've gotten from
friends and everywhere
and they're more organic.
And I want-- I kind
of want to fool people
into thinking that they're
not computer drawings.
And there is a warmth
there that comes from that.
It simulates--
the pressure I use
simulates a Sharpie,
which is something
we do at work where
you take a Sharpie
and you cut the end of it so
that it has a chisel edge.
And then you can get
a thick and thin,
depending on your pressure.
So that's what
this pressure does.
So it's limiting in
a way, but that's
how it should be because real
artist tools are limiting.
AUDIENCE: How do
you train yourself
to get that-- any suggestions?
BRIAN KESINGER: Just
practice, because it's
very weird drawing on a Cintiq.
It's like drawing
on ice, you know?
There's no tooth
to it or anything.
So we do most of our storyboards
at the studio on Cintiqs,
so that's every day, you know,
nine hours a day drawing on it.
So you put your hours and
then you get used to it.
But, yeah.
Don't get frustrated
when you first try,
because it does
feel pretty alien.
But, yeah.
Ultimately you get there.
AUDIENCE: Awesome, thanks.
BRIAN KESINGER: Thank you.
Yeah, go for it.
AUDIENCE: So first off I want
to thank you for coming here.
BRIAN KESINGER: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm sure
everyone here agrees.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm really happy that I got a
chance to come meet you here
because apparently I missed
you at the Geeky Tee's
grand opening where--
BRIAN KESINGER: Oh, bummer.
AUDIENCE: I was told
that you came and went
while I was in the other room.
BRIAN KESINGER: Yes, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the question
I have is, to a degree,
for my wife who is a--
she's in TV animation.
And they tend to do all
traditional animation.
Still digital, but 2-D.
BRIAN KESINGER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And sort
my general question
for anyone in the
industry is how do you
feel about that shift where
more things-- especially
in features-- have
gone to 3-D CG
and you do you, at any point,
miss the traditional aspects,
whether it be
digital or on paper?
BRIAN KESINGER: Yeah,
that's a good question.
I miss drawing
sometimes, which is why I
do all this stuff on the side.
But there's a great animation
book, The Illusion of Life
by Frank and Ollie,
is one of the nine--
there were two of the
nine old men, Disney's
original animators.
And they did this book, it's
like the Bible on animation
called The Illusion of Life.
And I feel that
that's what animation
is, the illusion of life.
And the more we can do to make
that illusion real, the better.
Which is where I see a
lot of strength of CG
and where I think a
lot of the audience
feels drawn into these
worlds that we do.
Especially when you
go to see Moana,
I mean the stuff
in there is just--
it's like all goosebumps.
And it's stuff that you can't
really get with 2-D. That said,
I love movies like
Secret of Kells.
And-- what's the other one
he did-- Song of the Sea.
Tomm Moore.
And I love Fantastic
Mr. Fox and Kubo.
I think there's lots of room.
I think what's nice
is that there's
more diversity in the
media then there was.
It used to kind of
be, like, all 2-D
and then the outlier
was maybe stop motion.
But now we're
starting to see more,
and to me that's a good thing.
And what's nice
about storyboarding
is it doesn't matter if it's
a CG production, hand-drawn,
or stop motion.
It all needs to be story boarded
first and so, for job security
sake, story boardings a
place that I recommend
a lot of artists who
really want to draw
as their career look into.
That and visual development.
But does that answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BRIAN KESINGER: In
another long winded way?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BRIAN KESINGER: OK, cool.
Thank you.
Anything else?
Yeah.
Please, step up to the mic.
AUDIENCE: So I just wanted to
let everybody know that I'm
married because of Brian.
So--
BRIAN KESINGER: Mmm.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BRIAN KESINGER: That
was pretty special.
AUDIENCE: It was.
BRIAN KESINGER: And
requires some explanation,
that sentence.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: If you just stop
by the tea room and bend five
and I'll tell you the story.
It's a great story.
Everybody else has
had to hear it.
But--
BRIAN KESINGER: Uh huh.
AUDIENCE: Anyway.
So obviously Otto and
Victoria and the Tea Girls
hold, like, a big
place in my heart.
And I was just wondering--
because I know how successful
your Kickstarter for
Dressing Your Octopus was--
BRIAN KESINGER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --so I was
wondering if that's
where you plan on kind of
ending with those characters?
Or if you have any future
plans for Otto and Victoria
or for the Tea Girls.
BRIAN KESINGER: I do, actually.
For both.
Thank you.
And-- Yeah, we're working
on-- I'm doing a third book.
So I just did a paper
doll book that, again,
in embracing kind of the old
world toy and steampunk vibe.
I thought, well why
have a real toy when
you could have paper dolls?
Because that's what they
would have had back then.
So I talked to my publisher and
we decided to do a Kickstarter
for a paper doll book
that went really well.
But I'm doing another
narrative book,
so I did Walking Your Octopus,
Traveling With Your Octopus
and I'm doing a
third one now called
Time Traveling
With Your Octopus.
So I get to do medieval
punk, and rikoko punk,
and future punk.
So as I expanded the world
in the traveling book,
I hope to expand over time
with the traveling book.
And then I am really
excited because I'm
big into tabletop
games, so we're
working on a Otto and
Victoria board game.
So that's going
to be really fun,
and I'm really excited to
do the art for the boards,
and the cards, and-- it's going
to be a million components,
but--
AUDIENCE: You just made my year.
BRIAN KESINGER: Yay.
Yay.
And we'll probably be play
testing it at Geeky Teas, too.
AUDIENCE: Yes!
I'm going to be there.
With green hair.
BRIAN KESINGER: Awesome.
Thank you.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Keep it short.
But since that you
mention now that you're
going to be doing
a time traveling,
would you ever
consider taking them
into the world of
Kazuo Yamazaki?
BRIAN KESINGER: Oh,
that would be awesome.
AUDIENCE: I think
that would be great.
BRIAN KESINGER: Yeah, in fact--
AUDIENCE: I'd love to
see that, actually.
BRIAN KESINGER: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like a spin off of
Calcifer or something from--
BRIAN KESINGER: Yeah.
Oh, that would be awesome.
I love those movies and
actually- I'm trying to think,
I haven't done a mash up
of them-- with them yet.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that'd be cool.
I mean, I'll look out for that.
BRIAN KESINGER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You got me excited,
because once you said that I
was like, I was going to see
if you're-- going to ask you
if you're going to
ever visit that world.
But now that you said that
your going to do time travel,
you could throw that in there.
BRIAN KESINGER: Right.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
BRIAN KESINGER: Oh, yeah.
Munn and OK Victoria
would be awesome.
AUDIENCE: Sit here and
listen [INAUDIBLE].
BRIAN KESINGER:
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi, love your art.
BRIAN KESINGER: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Really exciting.
So one of our family
friends is a student
at the art center studying
visual development.
BRIAN KESINGER: Oh, great.
AUDIENCE: And one of the
questions that came up
was as a person working in an
animation studio like Disney
or DreamWorks, how
much of that art
is actually visible
to the public?
Do those visual development
layouts actually
showing in the movie?
Or is it all sort of digitized?
And is there art just for people
who are working internally?
BRIAN KESINGER:
Yeah, it's more that.
It's more internal.
It's funny, visual
development and story
are more invisible art.
Right?
Like, they're very
important to the process,
but ultimately they're just
a step to the final goal.
The nice thing about
visual development
is they usually put out
art books for these movies,
and that's the bread and
butter for those books.
Because of all the beautiful
visual development.
So it does get seen and-- but
it's usually in that form.
But if the painting
itself isn't seen,
it's certainly felt.
All the information
that's put in there, all the
knowledge of color, of scale,
all those principles
are what make
a movie-- like what
we do at Disney--
look as rich as they do.
Because we have these
visual development people
that are just fine
artists to start,
and then they get
into animation.
I caution people--
it's interesting,
there's a trend
now of people, oh.
I want to be an animator, so
they just go learn animation.
But if you look
at all the people
that started the Disney
studio, started the heritage,
they were all artists first.
And then put their
art into the films.
So it's tricky, because there
is a lot more great animation
instruction out
there, but remember
to balance that out and not
just make cartoons all day.
As much as that's fun to do.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
BRIAN KESINGER: Cool, thank you.
Well, thank you so much guys.
I really appreciate your time.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]